that in fact brother Eddie I was sick
for long long long time suddenly I was
on my bed early and in the hospital for
a few a few years actually waiting for
my liver transplant and the humble
herbal I mean the doctor gave me three
months to live
that's it even after the transplant
after I woke up from my coma I wasn't a
call of course I cannot more organize my
own self my own kids didn't step by step
I start to remember myself and the kids
and family and the only thing I remember
very well that I am still in Palestine
me elaborate Palestine in Gaza Strip
could I grow up there and when the
people start to speak English in fact I
was speak English with them it was funny
you know I thought that I'm stealing
Gaza didn't I recognize myself I'm here
in America it was a hardship the only
thing I believe with all my respect to
have a doctor like here even doctors and
no one benefits me except the drought
the people Allah accepted Wow they gave
you how long to live three months three
months that's what the doctor said if
any month I live but and everybody give
up even me it's all luck here my wife
Annie she really helped me a lot she all
but know you're gonna live don't worry
you always do Dawa for Allah Allah Allah
the people made to offer me everybody
make a drama in fact that day I found
out all of all over all over America
actually different country they all was
texting and calling texting calling the
dryer Allah except with no questions
asked no doctors all my respect no
engineer no no the nurse no medicine
nothing and endow hamdullah my life
don't have you it shows you who's really
in charge huh indeed he's he's the one
how long's it been that you now you went
above and beyond the three months I
wasn't in the hospital actually waiting
for my list
five years actually three is I'm out of
it but the last two years one year and a
half two years out you know a correctly
was even myself how did you feel now
when you're when you're told you got
three months to live this life now
change like how did you feel when you
got that news what goes through your
mind what are you thinking
I was afraid what could happen agrees
I was afraid all of us were gonna die a
lot there's a coolness in Vietnam every
soul gonna die I remember all the only
thing I remember in the Quran was
reciting Quran all the time all the time
especially in the ayat good enough sit
back got a note if this old girl died
and remember when the Prophet SAW Allah
really slammed quinium Hamid s magic fan
muhammad o muhammad live as long as you
live never die grab my [ __ ] the fitna
come Oh father love anyone love I shall
of his father my unity and why man -
it's a magician I do whatever Allah will
give you what you want always a room
product really when I woke up from my
coma
my wife is Allah can she carry me with a
wheelchair specially for Ganesha because
I insisted even wheelchair I cannot walk
I cannot walk she carry me in the boot
miniature
all the way I pray with the people
especially for Ganesha I try to stand
I wonder stand up just like everybody
else in fact dr. Jackie from Boca ratone
I was in a wheelchair this Boca ratone
Masjid was so happy because I was a man
there and the brother worked very very
hard
oh and the only thing I remember by the
way Palestine Mecca Medina and Boca
Raton Florida
the only thing I remember actually from
my coma and then they invite me to come
I went one week at first after one
before nine months after its I start to
speak but still a wheelchair from the
airport I said to her car before go to
the hotel and believe it or not I won
the wheelchair and a stick and told my
wife I want to make stitute impossible
to execute and believe me a loss of
Hanoi tada make me make sued in boca de
toros I was dreamed to come and had in
fact believe it or not brother ready the
doctor gave me
impossible get a walk I was in my bed
like this and I told my wife and he hid
him behind my wife I need say I'm a
cochlea for everybody and Allah cure
everyone let me make rock clear for
myself because I tried to make to shoot
only rock dude I can't she hold me hold
me and her son
we just to sit I can't make us to shoot
or the pool and one day I told the
police I want to make broccoli for
myself I make actually I need a cup
bucket of water bucket warm water it was
in winter and have some came from
Ambra something is not a condition to
get them and I made surah till said her
older brother Eddie our hamza seven
times through the fire only but with
Tamina and understand it I understand
from that and I told her let me carry me
to the bathroom and let me take a shower
with the water see she carry the water
and she carry me to the bathroom and I
said please leave us impossible because
I cannot read here hold me if I in the
bathroom she have told me and she say
pleased I mean believe it or not more
than almost 15 minutes just doing
encourage her to go outside she waited
outside close the door what I did they
take this
water I make a rule I'm a poodle inside
the bathroom and then I cannot carry has
more cup just like this it's not cup on
my body all my body after will do of
course and now we're gonna stand up
alone she's outside and believe it or
not I stood up not only that I have to
walk and they step out properly I step
outside alone and then they opened the
door
Salam alaikum Annie I open my is
impossible to make to do this and I
mixed a dude and to raka for sugar lots
of hard work and then after that I go
home then instead go figure in Asia five
times there was a message now I have the
reply and because of the dot and
especially the way I pray in that time
in the sort of fact how only suicide a
lot of people do remember once we spoke
about hazard and this in years ago about
the hazard and that mean word rocker and
that people making some kind of magic
and this yeah I remembered myself
actually I didn't make anything other
than truth it sat outside the bathroom
mmm-hmm believe it or not a loss product
I'll accept
so yeah many people forget ok you try
all the physical means but now people
forget about the spiritual means so you
did all the physical means you went to
the doctors you did you took all the
pills you did all of that but now what
proved at the end I mean doesn't mean
that you go away from the physical means
but many people they they forget about
this is how powerful this is
and you did that you know brother ID
when I wake up from my coma I look open
my eyes my life next to me Annie
hey Annie did I pray dog by the way when
I oh no come a few months I cannot even
pray because I am out of it
I said don't worry because I cannot move
I said please I pray it was Margaret
died I thought I said last year to my
trip she and she said no I don't pray
she pleased I'm I'm a poodle
she carry me to the bathroom I mean I
believe it or not I pray certain degree
of Salah every time I pray with voice
sorted Fatiha
I believe it was Indians o Nasrallah
Fatiha and also follow Allah that's it
but with my inner relaxation when I
witness a lot I didn't believe it or not
I start to concentrate to teach how the
broth of sempre say can you tell us now
give it just just something when I asked
you earlier